hey guys this is Dennis the founder
thank Cara and I'm David Griffin your
resident comic book and video game guru
and this is our review of Game of
Thrones season 4 episode 7 Mockingbird
yes oh yeah what a great episode yeah
yeah so let's start in the the main
stuff Tyrion King's Landing gets visited
by the three girl ghosts of Christmas
some great conversation we'll start off
with Jaime
it's kind of the aftermath of the trial
yeah you and Jaime's pissed because
Jamie was willing to sacrifice so much
for him and hearing kind of just threw
it all away right I mean these scenes
what I love about him is you not only
get to know more about cheering and what
he's singing but about I guess you'd
call him the closest thing he has to
friends first and foremost is Jaime the
one who's always supported him and that
was a great scene I mean he's like he
admits to be like it was good to spoil
fathers plans exactly it's good to tell
everyone off and all that often and then
Jamie made a good points like is your
pride you know worth your life right
yeah like you know and also basically
that I can't fight for you he lets him
know I can't fight for you yes I
wouldn't lose he would lose he goes but
I like to that you know cheering kind of
made a jest about him sleeping with
Cersei and he's like careful like I'm
the only friend you have left and he's
like such a good moment between those
two yeah and you can see now more than
before that they have a relationship
they have a good relation right it's
basically you know the only good one in
the land yeah it's not easy being a
Lannister so much treachery and people
wanted to kill their own brothers and
sisters and some incest it's not easy
okay so let's get on to Bronn like that
I did not expect to see Bronn like that
I knew Bronn probably wasn't gonna fight
for for Tyrion because you know the way
he is I mean they've set him up is okay
he's just so sort yeah that's a
mercenary get whatever you know whoever
pays him the most and at this moment
Cersei has all the power and the Marine
position and all that stuff of course
she's gonna you know they'll buy him off
and but I didn't expect him to come
dress like that though yeah you look
good guys new clothes
looks all frou-frou even Bally's like my
lord like and bow tie like though that
he didn't end up being a bad guy he's
just practical he's like look man I like
you I just love myself more I thought
that was a great line it was a great
line he also said I am your friend yeah
but when have you ever risked your life
for me cuz he hasn't he just buys
everything you guys prompt rise to
basically just buy his problems away
wants to survive and he's like maybe I
could beat the mountain but if I danced
around but he's like he's like I
shouldn't be scared of that dude he's
like I mean I mean like you said you
know he Tyrion has never done anything
for him except give him money yeah you
know just tries to buy his problems away
that's it and I like that they kind of
acknowledge each other that they are who
they are basically and they they accept
their faults yeah they know you know
Terry knows what kind of person Braun is
Bryan knows what kind of person Tyrion
is yeah and at the end when they you
know weave things they make peace yeah
they make peace but I mean in bronze
money it's like well this is the last
time I'm gonna it was good I mean I I'm
gonna I love their camaraderie you know
I mean they're such good of carryover
since they were introduced you know he
fought for
fought for him up in the Vale and been
in his honor the first time I mean all
these conversations all these
visitations Tyrion had were just so good
I mean you know Jamie over and broad I
mean they're just so they're they're so
good no well let's speak of Oberyn yeah
this was my favorite seat definitely in
the whole episode and this is the
episode filled with great right right
just him coming in there and giving that
story because we know that kind of all
this kind of hardship that that Tyrion
has grown up with being a dwarf you know
between his father and his sister and in
the rest of I guess the Kingdom
everybody that's down on him and makes
fun of him sense but adorn they don't
have any stipulations with bastards they
they like them they're respected and
even like you said
a story like with doors like the outcast
basically Dorne seems to embrace
outcasts they don't seem to have the
same prejudice that the rest of the
Seven Kingdoms and this is a story that
Oberyn tells terian that tearing himself
doesn't know yeah that gives insight
into him and I mean Peter Dinklage his
acting his reaction Oh fantastic like I
said I loved that scene as soon as
Prince Oberyn says all I saw was a baby
like you to see him like start choking
because for once he heard his birth
story from a perspective of a guy he
liked look I see you as a human being
you're not a monster
you know I don't think Oberyn they're
gonna be best buddies necessarily cuz
oberyn's got his own scores on Genda
he's got his own agenda BAE's like
you're not a monster you know it's like
and he acknowledged him as a human being
I don't think cheering gets that -
awesome yeah and you know how he was
disappointed there yeah I see the
monster with the big head and the red
eye and the claw and the tail and all
that stuff but then you know telling him
that oh yeah and then search they showed
us and basically you know grabbed his
wiener and Jamie of course stopped it
even back then he was still sucking up
for Tyrion exactly it just tells you so
much right yeah about where they are
today
right and this is a story about them way
in the past when they're just children
ya know I want to say this cuz I know
that Peter Dinklage he's getting all the
accolades which he deserves he's the
first name that pops up in the credits
he's is probably the I don't know what
they're paid arts kill him he might be
one of the highest-paid actors there
that's fine but I think Pedro Pascal oh
he's awesome he's just I mean as a
Prince Oberyn is just did he stood
toe-to-toe with Peter Dinklage in his
act he's great
well he's the best new character this
season like last season I thought
what's-her-face Diana Rigg is Elena yeah
she was great - yeah it was it was the
best edition this year is definitely not
Pedro Prescott yeah yeah he's just just
telling that so Xavier him speak outside
of you know interview he doesn't really
have much of an actor he doesn't sounds
like a regular dude it's like not much
of an accent but he's just kind of you
know bringing this new character to us I
think he's doing a great job yeah and
then of course when he you know he's
like What did he say
oh he was like oh I'm looking for
justice and then Peter yeah I'm serious
like oh if you come to find justice
you've come to the wrong place
he's like no I found the perfect place
pretty grabs like the torch music comes
on yeah yeah well it's like relief and
all this you know all this emotion and
right so you're getting ahead of myself
next to or we have to week we have a
little bit of a break we've got Memorial
Day weekend coming out here over here in
the States
the next episode is called I think
believe like the mountain and the Viper
you know so we get to see you know the
Viper is you know Prince over and you
know we know that at least from his
reputation the dude can fight so but if
you've seen the the next week's preview
yeah I feel like one second of the phone
and you see Prince Oberyn is like this
big and the mountain is like gigantic
yeah speaking of the mountain you know
we saw him killing people so check out
this is the third actor playing the
mountain it's third out which guy they
want to get to play this reversed one
Spartacus he and the second one was a
temporary solution it was like I think
actor showed up in maybe one episode in
season 2 this guy was showing Dennis
earlier that he's a there's a nice
picture with him I don't know if Lena
Headey had he tweeted it out but it's a
picture of them together like I think
offset or something like that and he is
a world Strongest Man competitor from
Iceland I think he's six nine 415 pounds
like Levi basically found the biggest
dude they could find and he I mean he
looks the part I'm sure he probably
can't act that mo well I mean no he's do
say all right you know he says like you
know but he looks great
he's huge he looks great so that's
everyone's waiting for that of course it
said two weeks when I told some friends
I was like two weeks they were pissed
they're like what oh I I love watching
Cersei just like walk over the guts in
gore was like she didn't even flinch
she's like just smile she's excited yeah
like you're looking good for him but she
made one fatal mistake
she picked someone that has a past
mmm-hmm that someone would want to fight
him for right yeah someone had
be a little crazy but right Prince
Oberyn is a little he's easy he goes all
out
he likes to experience every definitely
a man of passion here's a bit of fashion
all right so let's go go back to
dragonstone and go see Millis Andre and
the print I forget her dances dances
wife yeah you know she Chris you know
van Halen there's no problem earning
bearing all in front of the screaming in
her bath oh that was actually I feel
like we're gonna talk about Jon Snow in
a little bit I feel like these two
scenes very forget it forget about mean
the good scenes it's just that in
compared to the rest of the episode
which is so good especially with all the
stuff with Tyrion yeah I feel like I
didn't focus on this as much but yeah
I'd almost forgotten about the metal
right but I'm though we at least got to
see more of Stannis's wife because I
feel like she's very underused because
mill saundra kind of takes up the screen
she dominates and obviously Stannis is
there we get a little more insight I
guess you know there's a prophecy
something like needs to happen where
Santa says daughter needs to come with
them when they take their journey so I
mean that's you know I got me that guess
that some insight into there and Milla
saundra kind of admits it some of the
stuff she does it's for show we got some
of that yeah it was weird she was trying
to explain it like somehow through the
deception you see the truth right I
don't know but yeah we'll see that
hopefully play out later so now on to to
Jon Snow he comes back from Craster's
keep right answer alice's giving him
crap again getting again i mean he just
he can't get anything going i mean he's
got a good idea was like let's you know
he lost a tunnel but the one builder who
you could tell i think its agree with
him he was like no i don't agree then
kind of put his head down and you know
he's basically under the thumb of sir
alistair and the other guy who was he
formerly of the gold cooks it go cloves
he's also a jerk everybody's against Jon
Snow even though cuz he's just a steward
and he needs to like clean out the
chamber pots and stuff so he can't get
anything done again not a bad scene just
there's so much going on this episode
they kind of forget about it and I think
you know you know in him and Sam you're
gonna get punished
have to stand guard at night until you
know I guess two weeks or something
until everybody's gonna come down from
the wall or from the north there's kind
of some foreshadowing we're in Johnson I
was talking about the Giants yeah that
was good I like the Giants yeah and them
coming in and possibly knocking things
over I [ __ ] that the bars over and so
hopefully we got to see that later on
yeah to see you right in some sort of
when Mance's army descends down on the
wall right yeah and then I guess moving
let's I guess let's just talk with about
Danny okay you know Denarius over there
marine holding court doing her thing and
it starts off with a nice little
romantic scene Dario I feel like this
episode I'm like okay I think it's hard
to like him now I didn't dislike him it
just took a second to get used to the
new Dario because they changed cast and
then I'm looking at the guy and like
okay I think this episode I'm starting
to like him he snuck into her private
chambers which basically says he could
kill her at any time that he but they're
just basically trusting because he's you
know in love with her yeah and you know
she decides he hates yeah decides to get
some now she's on the other end where
she's a ruler and is ordering him to
strip down and get naked and so yeah and
then she gets hurt her needs fulfilled
yeah let's see what Jordan the morning I
was like oh oh hey are you here to see
our queen she's a good mood this morning
Lord friendzone is not happy no no and
then of course when he sees Danny she's
wearing her looking good well I just had
sex out oh yeah good yeah that was great
but I did like the scene even though
we're short because we got to see some
insight in terms of okay Drori can sway
yeah it's Danny in terms of cuz she
wants to go out there go back
send Dario why's everybody out yeah kill
all the Masters at Yong Chi and take him
out and and he tells the stories like
well I used to you know oh you know well
slaves it wasn't the Ned Stark his the
mercy start
I would be dead and you were the ruler
and I would have been killed
yeah and so then she just changes her
mind says okay just and she does a thing
which is kind of like a game playing
where's like yeah not don't tell him I
changed my mind tell him you you good
job yeah yeah like make him feel he's
like oh I feel good because you know
George does an attraction to Danny's
obsessed with he was obsessed or so you
know see another man you know get to you
know have sex with her he's like you
know like I got something going Tom to
you I can influence her so that was a
good that was a good scene it's nice to
Danny but then you know after all that
then that kind of leads us into talking
about Arya and the Hound who could be
the best you know grouping on television
period you can just make a whole show oh
yeah yeah definitely we see some of the
hounds compassion in this episode with
the man dying you see him give him water
yeah you know him you think he would
just kill him first and be like I don't
want to race the resources exactly but
it was kind of what he was saying in a
previous centre so when they stole the
the money from that one family things
like well they're gonna die anyways I'm
gonna take it this man that's dying you
see that he actually has compassion on
him yeah was something new yeah
Arya is getting deep well she's getting
deep it she's getting darker because now
she's like oh nothing is is nothing yeah
no yeah versus like oh she didn't really
yeah I think the old Arya would have
been upset about the Hound kilmer see
killing me yeah yeah and not
understanding the situation but I think
she's she's gotten darker and deeper you
know life is worn her down and she now
sees kind of the reasoning behind that
well the thing is Arya she's in a really
dark place because she has no hope for
anything beyond this world whereas let's
take me long difference and she is very
spiritual so even though stuff you know
the night of the night is dark and full
of terror she acknowledges that but in
that she has lord of light everything
else
Sansa has her fairytale hopes and dreams
even though she's getting little dark
herself I mean
but yeah areas like life is crap i watch
his head chopped off my brothers
brothers dead my mom's dead
I'm with this like basically the baddest
man besides the mountain
you know who's one of the meanest guys
out there I'm with him this is what I'm
doing I'm killing people now obviously
she had no problem killing that guy you
know he's like I love that see when
she's like he can't be on my list I
don't know his name
and then the said is dead he's like woo
you got of it that's great yeah and she
also is learning from from the Hound
like I had said in a previous episode
you know she learned where the heart was
to kill him and also then she wipes off
the needle just like the hounded was
like killed killed that guy
yeah and then of course I the great
scene with them you know with her
cleaning his wound and him telling the
story about taking one of great gregor
clegane you know the mountain taking his
toy and then a fire and how that his dad
you said his brother these but tricks
his brother betrayed him and Arya is
like oh my brother gave me this sword I
have a you know until the old a lot of
them are dead now but I had a great
family you know who loved me and
everything and he didn't have any of
that so no and you can kind of see this
bond growing between the two even though
the Hound is on her list great and she's
slowly seen that this guy isn't as evil
or as bad as I thought he was he was
trying to be me and he said I wish I'd
never met you then he looked over there
but he felt bad about saying that also
they learned that Joffrey was dead is
the first time they heard because of the
bounty on the hounds head they thought
it was for telling a Joffrey to [ __ ] the
king right yeah right but that's not in
it's it's you know for killing those
other Lannister soldiers yeah and so you
know I think already disappointed cuz I
think Arya wanted to kill him herself
right but you know the guy offers off
her list she's good I mean yes I mean
their interactions are great I mean of
course they're not the only duo middle
Westeros other goods you know Podrick
and Brienne and Brienne let's you know
that's that's also the good do two who
meet up with hot pie yeah also I didn't
think this is a pretty popular spot it
must be located in a section where next
it's like in-and-out burger in LA
everybody goes to this spot about their
like Ari
in the Brotherhood weren't there those
things were in they went to in the first
season when they're on their way down
the Kings Road actually I think it's
just like this is the spot but yeah they
see hot pot hot pie and yeah I love the
interactions between Brienne and Podrick
right yeah because he's kind of a loyal
servant but you know a little a little
quirky yeah he's so blunt yeah you know
like you can drink when you can't get
drunk yeah don't get drunk
yeah and you know oh we need to treat
ourselves and we can sleep on a bed
tonight with feathers don't expect any
other like silk pajamas yeah I just love
this this duo and then of course they
learn about Aria from which you know
leads them to to the path to the veil
yeah it was great scene hot pie again I
like that he made her another you know a
bread or something you know Carville
direwolf that's better this time
yes laughs yeah last time it looked like
it kind of looked like the wolf but it's
all messed up and this one's like all
detailed all this stuff on it I mean how
fires moving up to a executive chef I
mean he's he's getting good the boy can
make himself a kidney pie yes and then
he has to tell everyone about it and
tell them about it people forget about
the gravy in the grave it was nice to go
I love Popeye talking about like those
folks from winter he'll like he's
already 80 still thinks it because you
were armor you must be yeah that's one
like season two yeah yeah I mean the
thing about the show is like it pays off
like they actually referred in season 2
and season 1 are coming you know they're
happy they have consequences even if
it's a small conversation with hot by
and then there's just so much humor and
there's so many layer and there's all
these things and people say yeah
I mean then it was cool scene Podrick
used the knowledge that Tyrion said you
know you need to learn the names of
every major house and their family in
the lineage and so he has a good inkling
of where Sansa is and we're re in the
Hound which they are are probably
heading you know I guess which perfectly
you know sets us up for the final big oh
snap motive of mockingbird yeah so in
the values you know we see sanso come
out in and she sees the snow and tall
yeah she reminds her of Winterfell and
her face lights up so she builds that
who's Hotel hotel that she was I dare to
see anybody else in the north build a
better snow castle I mean I was like
dang that's a good girl you're not that
good and then of course we have the
other like crazy oh that kid my kid I
wanna see the fly yeah says people he's
I I was so happy when she slapped that
kid upside his face I wanted to see her
do it twice and then we also see Petyr
Baelish come in and there was like it's
weird creeping behind that course ways
like children this is creeping behind
that corner so then he kind of has this
nice moment with Sansa and then it turns
creepy like after that kiss did you see
his face like he has that look kind of
like it's like this weird creepy like
older man look it's just weird
well the nice moment I'm talking about
is where she asked him like really why
did you kill Joffrey and he's like what
do we do to the ones that hurt or like
hurt the ones we love you know that's a
smile like yeah they get a little bit
darker to herself well yeah they had
this moment and then he went into this
whole thing about her mom and you're
you're more beautiful than your mom I
loved her if things that turn out well
you would have been my daughter then he
kisses her too soon creepy so creepy
yeah so yeah and then of course there's
like total Hitchcock moment where then
they pan up right there you up there in
the corner like the one thing I did
notice like what the Sansa thing is okay
she didn't want to be kissed mm-hmm and
she was kind of weirded out by it yeah
but she at the same time she didn't like
shove him no I mean she wasn't I mean
she closed her eyes and let it happen
for a few seconds I mean the end she was
like oh wait not probably yeah I mean it
was creepy but she yeah she's like
totally fine and then let's doesn't have
the best luck with men no I thought that
that's why she was being called in to
Lysa she took over not for the kids for
the slappy
Robin yeah Robin yeah yeah we had the
moondoor sequence where she's like that
coming again as a book we ride yeah that
was gonna happen and I like the way they
said you think you see him as soon as
Peter came into the picture and then I
was like okay he's gonna boot all right
I gotta bust out tha this is sparta no
but once he's stopped her like at first
I thought because it is Game of Thrones
yeah that possibly Sansa could die or
Lysa could have got thrown in by Sansa
like yeah you know she was kind of
threatening her by telling her the story
and what people look like at that and
yeah flying off but once Baelish came in
and said lights a stop I was like okay
he's gonna push ya hurry and yeah you
know tell you know she's obviously crazy
and jealous because she's obsessed with
him and of course he burns her at the
end like I only loved one woman yeah
bye-bye
that's how we end the episode yeah it
was these last weeks have been great
these last weeks have been really strong
it's um so in particular it was great
and this was written by Weiss and
Benioff I thought yeah this is a great
episode so only three left only three
left and we got to wait two weeks till
the next one and everyone's waiting for
that mountain versus Viper yeah fight
scene it's gonna be yeah it's gonna be
great all right guys so that's what we
thought of this episode of Game of
Thrones let us know what you think and
post your comments below on the website
thank eurocom or on our youtube channel
think hero pro make sure to subscribe to
that you can also come find this on
Twitter Dennis and myself we're at think
hero let us know what you thought about
this week's episode as well as what we
thinks gonna happen no spoilers please
and I'm at Griffin de we also have a
Facebook page that's facebook.com slash
think hero fans make sure you like that
page share a video and Twitter Facebook
and other social media
you